[Music]
good afternoon everybody my name is
Stefan oz and I'm a product manager for
Gmail and today I'm very excited that
we're announcing a completely new way of
integrating your apps functionality
right into Gmail right when the user
needs it most and not just on Gmail for
web but also natively on Android and on
iOS and how this works I'll tell you
later during this session and I'm super
excited that it's not just me talking
about Gmail add-ons today but we
actually have three over very valuable
partners with me today that we'll be
showing off a demo of the add-ons that
they've been building over the past few
weeks using this new framework I'll
introduce you I'll introduce them to you
later during this session first let's
start taking a look at this big shift
that's been happening in application
software recently and it's called the
clouds specifically when we look at the
workplace we see that there's all these
types of software like project
management CRM invoicing and it's all
moving into the clouds and if it's not
there already and now let's take a look
at how email behaves in this space
between all these different types of
productivity software for many of us
email is the central place where stuff
happens at work whether it's good or bad
email is basically a task list for us
and for most of us this means that we're
switching constantly between Gmail and
other types of productivity applications
for example if I'm a marketer I'm
switching between Gmail and Marketo
if I'm in an HR person I'm switching
between Gmail and LinkedIn or if I'm if
I'm a salesperson I switch between my
CRM and an Gmail and as you've heard
this morning during prabhakar keynotes
chief sweets is not just a random bunch
of apps now it's actually a very
thoughtful work force platform where
each and end division every individual
app is meant to work very well together
and there's a lot of deep integrations
between the individual gmail apps which
were which we're launching more and more
and we recognize that people are not
just using Gmail apps or G suite apps at
work they're using all these other apps
that we just talked about and that's why
we acknowledge that G suite apps needs
to work very well with all the other all
the other cloud applications we all know
this right it's a pain for me my browser
tabs they're often so narrow that I
don't even see the icons anymore and it
really drives the point home
switching contacts is a pain and let's
not even start talking about how this is
on mobile because I'm mobile
I mean even if you have installed the
app already it's just it's just annoying
and we all know that we're doing more
and more on our phones when we look at
this graph we see that the number of
emails that we're opening is a lot more
on mobile than on that stuff and what's
even more apparent here is that the
rates this increases is is much stronger
on mobile and that's why we're
introducing Gmail add-ons today a new
extensibility framework to integrate
your apps functionality into Gmail right
when the user needs it most
natively on Android and on iOS and a web
without further ado let me show you demo
of what this actually means
could we should switch to the Chromebook
the other screen on the Chromebook
please okay let me yeah let me set that
straight it's fixed yeah not a problem
all right so what we're looking at here
this is my know box and I cleaned it up
for the moment and you see Ivan Ivan
email from my coworker
enesta and it has the subject catching
up after coffee so let's take a look at
it what she what she's actually asking
so she asked me hey do you have time to
catch up of coffee I'm available at 3:00
p.m. next Friday and she sent this a few
days ago to me so now if we look at the
right-hand side of the screen here we
see we see an icon and this is the
Google calendar icon it's
it's in black and white though and this
is the Google Calendar add-on that we
built together with the team as an
initial prototype to show of what the
power is of these add-ons so this atom
it triggered for this email because
enesta asked me if I'm available to meet
with her so now when I tap on this icon
a panel comes up and what it does it
shows me what is my agenda for the
moment or for the day where she asked me
to meet so in this case she asked me to
meet at Friday tomorrow showed shows me
what is my agenda for tomorrow and so
see like I have a couple of events
already and from here it shows me
whether I'm busy or I'm free at the
specific time in this case I'm busy and
in fact I'm busy with the same event
catching up after coffee because I did
this demo 20 minutes ago and I forgot to
clean it up but that's nice because we
actually showed that it's actually
really working so but what I can do from
here I can actually send her a new
invitation or I can just open up a thing
in Google Calendar and then from there
from there do something so now I want to
show you that I can actually create an
invitation but I'm not going to show
that on the desktop I'm going to share
it on the phone because the key part of
the add-ons framework is that it's
cross-platform so if you could please
switch to the Android phone then we're
looking at my same inbox
I know that's the wrong device it's open
if you could switch through the iPhone I
can do it on the iPhone because it's
cross-platform
it's alright so here we're on the iPhone
and so I opened up the same message see
here same email in the bottom right
corner of my phone I see the same Google
Calendar icon
so when I tap on it you see the exact
same UI as we just saw a moment ago on
web natively rendered and so it shows my
agenda for Friday shows it like split
screen so I can see both the message
content and I can see the the content of
the add-on provides me in this case I
want to see it a bit bigger so I'm
making the add-on fullscreen and now
let's continue the demo does actually
wanted to show you is creating an event
so a tap on the create event button will
take me to a new screen and you see that
there are a lot of the event details
already automatically filled out by the
Google Calendar add-on so you see
there's a title that suggests that the
guests or the participants already fill
out and the date at a time now I can add
in a location to the event or a
description in this case I'm not going
to do that but I am going to toggle
sending invitations because then a nest
I will know that I said actually wanted
to meet with her so now I press save and
I get a confirmation when I tap on view
event it will open up in a Google
Calendar app in this case no real need
for that
so I just step ok and then I gotta get a
confirmation over here can we go back to
the slides so this was a nice demo of a
of an integration between Google
Calendar and Gmail but what I'm even
more excited about is that some of our
partners have been building even better
integrations and I'd like to introduce
Ursula chick offender a product manager
at prosper works to show off the
demonstration of the ad on the day of
built over the past weeks
thank you can we get the pixel device to
show my name is Ursula in for those of
you who are not familiar with prosper
works we're a CRM solution born to
address the problem of complexity with
CRM by focusing on automation and ease
of use and two ways we were able to
accomplish that as actually there
involves Google so we were able to
integrate with the GC apps and we're
also adopted to adopted material design
which gives our users the look and feel
that they're so familiar with so we are
actually recommended in the G suite
marketplace that Google teams actually
are using prosper works we love
everything Google especially the pixel
so I'm glad it's showing up am I using
the iPhone instead alright first time on
the iPhone I really do prefer the pixel
and we were really excited when we
learned about this project so we were
thrilled to jump in and I'm gonna show
you what we have been working on great
so I'm gonna pretend just for you today
that I'm a salesperson and I'm on my way
and route to see a customer to show a
demo and what I'm gonna do is actually
is open up an email that I just happened
to receive from that very customer hey
Ursula I wanted to let you know that
Brian crushing a former colleague of
mine who is also looking for a simple
solution for his business will be
joining our meeting today great sounds
like a new lead what I'm gonna what am I
gonna do am I going to mark the email as
unread and then wait to add it into my
system later no I could open up the
prosper works up and then add that lead
but as you probably see coming there's a
ways your way to do that now I can
actually just tap on the prospects logo
here on the bottom right corner
and it pulls up all of the contacts that
are included in the email thread
so there's myself Ursula the system user
there's Ben was my contact and then
Brian crushing who was copied on the
email and if I select Brian I can
actually expand this card and get a feel
full view and again all the information
that prospects was able to gather about
that contact based on the email address
and I kind of add that person as a lead
there we go so I have that lead I don't
have to worry about it again until
prosper works reminds me later than I
need to follow up and I'm done so now
I'm gonna focus on my meeting that's
coming up and I want to do a very good
job on my demo and what I do for that is
actually look into Ben's information I
can get the full details of that contact
from Pross works and I can look at
activity so interactions that I've had
with this prospective clients in the
past be it notes that I made or calendar
events or phone calls that I've had with
this person I can see here on the top
note these are the things that he cares
about so I'm gonna be sure to touch on
those when I meet with him in person and
look totally prepared I can also see any
related items so that contact including
the opportunities tasks and calendar and
let's say maybe I want to dig a little
deeper and look at Maureen for this one
is not a set up but I could it deep
links actually into the prosper works
app which means that I don't have to
open up the app search for that contact
and waste time doing doing so switching
different to different apps from the
mobile devices ties was explaining it's
a little cumbersome I can actually just
do it right from the ad and it will take
me straight to the opportunity record
and show me any details so I went into
the demo it went great so flawless and I
wanna maybe write a quick thank-you note
to the client and while I'm in Gmail
might as well also log a note here
and make a note of the meeting that I
just had I'm gonna say demo went great
and maybe you're like I got a run of
applause maybe and then I'll save and
you'll notice that activity is now
logged into associated to that contact
and I'll see the same activity across
platform so the apps the web app and I'm
done and I know that our customers will
be chomping at the bit won't be able to
wait to get this functionality they're
gonna be probably as excited as we were
to work on this and I'm gonna give a
shout out to Steve ohm and Ben and Eric
who've worked on this and a huge thank
you to thighs and his team for making
this tool available which will make our
users lives so much easier can we switch
back to the slides thank you very much
Ursula and also thank you for being
flexible and doing the demo on a
different on a different device great so
when we think about what was the reason
why why we introduced gmail add-ons it's
all about making our users more
productive helping them waste less time
in Gmail and we did this by bringing you
bringing them your apps functionality
close to where they need it and and we
do this by showing those I'd those
add-on icons in the UI for each message
where it's relevant now
there's of course a risk here because
this might result in like a wildfire of
different icons for different add-ons so
what we did is we built the framework in
such a way that you can trigger your ad
on when it's contextually relevant so
for example the Google Calendar add-on
that you just saw it only triggered for
an email that contains for an intent
from the sender to set up a meeting
it doesn't just trigger if the meeting
contains the data or at I mentioned
there's actually an intent behind it
when the user wants to when the sender
of the email wants to meet
now I want to reiterate that it was very
important for us to make this
cross-platform
because we realized there were some
options today to extend gmail on the web
but given the rise of mobile usage we
wanted to make sure this was desktop and
mobile now with that we realized there
was no too good like development pattern
today to to do this on desktop or mobile
and especially not doing it efficiently
without a lot of hassle so we started
thinking about a new development
paradigm for these Gmail add-ons and
first of all Gmail add-ons they're
written in Apps Script if you're not
familiar with Apps Script Apps Script is
a JavaScript runtime in the cloud space
specifically built for integrating and
enhancing G Suite applications so with a
tons of api's to integrate with other G
suite apps like it's very easy to build
like a quick integration with Google
Drive Google Calendar and Google Docs
for example and now and it's also super
easy to hook up your own api's into Apps
Script you could already build Google
Docs add-ons with Apps Script but now
today you can also build Gmail add-ons
however this doesn't say anything yet
about like how does this cross-platform
and for that we build a new design
system using cards so let me walk
through that with an example so what
you're looking at here is like an
example atom that we call contacts and
what it does it shows for all the people
in an email conversation it will show me
some contact information coming from my
address book and I'm by means of this
add-on I'm going to tell you what what
the card system actually what the card
system actually means so in this case
all the information for one contact is
all on one card now a card consists of a
couple of individual components so
there's a header of the card in this
case the header contains like the
profile picture of the of the sender and
it contains the name of the contact
there's a couple of other variations
that we have but here's an example then
a card contains one or more sections and
in these sections you basically combine
your different UI elements and 42i
elements we call them widgets here
here's a here's an example of a widget
so where we
the email address of the of the sender
currently we have a whole library
available of UI widgets anything from
interactive widgets like text inputs
dropdowns checkboxes to information
representation widgets like images
paragraphs and label label description
pairs and sometimes your ad on it needs
to return multiple cards to the user so
in the case of this contacts app we
might want to show a card for each
person in the conversation also the
people at our sea seat for example and
in that case what our system will do is
it will collapse the multiple cards that
you have into one overview and then the
user can tap on an individual card to
expand it and and basically to do a deep
dive and that's for example what you saw
just in the prosper works add on just a
moment ago all right so that's the card
system but it's still pretty high level
so how does this look in code I want to
show you that by means of a very tiny
simplified example so I made the
contacts example even simpler so super
tiny cards with just the header than one
section that contains just the email
address of the sender and in the section
as a header so let's look at how this
looks in codes it's a first step we're
creating a new instance of a card by by
calling the Create card method now we're
getting this card a header because every
card needs a header and in that header
we're getting a two pieces of
information in this case the profile
picture of the sender and also the name
of the sender and as I mentioned before
there's a bunch of other variations you
can leave out the picture you can add
some other lines of text but this is
basically basically it now we're adding
a section to this card and in that
section we can use it to put our UI
widgets in there but first before
creating a section or before adding UI
widgets we want to give this section a
title or a header and that's optional
but in this case we're calling it
contact info and now let's create our
one and only UI widget which in this
case we use the key value widgets which
is pretty generic it's a way to create
pairs of a label and a description in
this case we're using an icon as a label
email icon and we're using the email
address as the description but there's a
bunch of other variations it's quite
flexible so as you see here this is
quite a short piece of code of course
also quite a quite a simple add-on but
it's really simple and the magic here is
like this transfer translates into a
nice UI fully material design not just
on one platform but on three and you've
already seen the demo on an Android or
on a Chrome device and on an iPhone and
hopefully the next demo we will do on an
Android device and with that I'd like to
introduce Kristoff Lutz key who is a
software engineer at Salesforce and he
will show you a demo that he built for
Salesforce add-on Oh everyone my name is
Chris hi my name is Christopher boot ski
I'm an engineer at Salesforce and I'm
gonna show you the stuff that we've
built with Google in the past couple of
weeks it's pretty exciting I'm gonna go
into my gmail switch to my account here
and essentially our use case is very
similar to prosper works we want to make
sure that our sales salespeople and
sales guys have a much easier time
getting information queried out of
Salesforce creating records inside
Salesforce without having to go and
break out into a browser and being able
to essentially do most of the stuff that
they would do they're directly through
the add-on and through this framework so
there is a list of emails that I have
you can imagine those being like like
business related emails where I would
like to pull in some context based on
the information there so I can click on
Salesforce cloud here and expand add-on
and there we go there's a list of people
that were created queried out of
Salesforce based on email addresses that
we have collected from Gmail and from
the message itself so here's a list of
them those are the matches that we've
come up with
so I'm gonna pick one for example marina
here and in there kind of like the
information that we can look up or just
email address location phone numbers but
on top of that we can also look up some
of the activities that they've that the
person has been up to so things that are
open the history of activities that they
have done so far based on you know the
business that they're looking for and
also opportunities so like you know
global media distribution rights and all
sorts of different things that are
related to that particular object in CRM
so that's pretty cool you can also break
out viewing in Salesforce you can take
this and break out to do more complex
set of things inside the browser itself
or inside that the native app so having
said that there's other things that you
can also do besides doing that which is
logging emails into Salesforce which is
a pretty interesting feature to to our
users specifically which allows you to
take the content of the message put it
inside Salesforce as different types of
objects whether it's a task or an email
item and then provide some sort of
context into who it's associated to so
those things are important for for sales
guys specifically when they're trying to
to essentially log and relate
information together to make some sense
out of it towards the end of the quarter
so you can select you know a task as the
target object or relate it to you can
pick let's say I don't know marina as
the person that is gonna be the who on
the object and you can also select
things that maybe are not in the list of
current contacts so most of the
information that you see there listed
came from the emails that were on the
message so if a person has an account
associated with it it's also pulled down
but that's not everything that you can
pull pull down you can for example
search for something specific that is
not listed there so Salesforce is a
pretty generic thing that should return
a bunch of records
so go through that click on search
that's gonna expand the list to things
like like leads we have some leads there
we have accounts we have more
opportunities so that will serve as for
example the the wot entity on the task
object so I will select the opportunity
sales force five hundred Wizards and
then up top the whole thing updates so
whenever you know you leave this and
then come back you can essentially look
back at this information and pull out
all the context that was saved there the
last time they've done that and that's
that's part of the demo
the really cool thing for me from like
an engineering perspective is that it
really took a very short period of time
to do all this stuff I mean it literally
from nothing to what we see there it
took about five days and it's pretty
polished there's like a lot of stuff
there that's that's pretty cool it fits
very well with like what we offer at
Salesforce with our existing
integrations and it's on mobile and it's
in the browser it's it's really awesome
from from my perspective was kind of
nice to build this that way and all that
the material UI is all built in there
you don't have to like fiddle with other
things it's all pretty much their own
there's the github thing anyway so yeah
really cool stuff we want to thank dice
for letting us to do all this stuff
and I'll pass the mic or do you know
Kristof super awesome demo and I'm
really impressed with how he built that
that whole add-on in just a matter of a
week fully functional so kudos for that
all right so can we switch back to the
slides
want to look at what does this mean for
our users now and it basically means
that all the apps and productivity tools
that you guys have built already can now
be brought to them right at the
fingertips at the place where they need
it most
at any platform where they where they
might use what I might use Gmail and
this will basically cause them to waste
less time and being more more productive
Gmail add-ons will be available through
the G suite marketplace this is a
marketplace where your current we're
currently able to get for example Google
Docs add-ons and the G speed marketplace
will be available or will be accessible
from within the Gmail app and you can
discover the add-ons that might be
relevant for your for your use cases and
Gmail add-ons will be available for both
consumer users as well as for enterprise
users of course so what does it mean for
developers well we just showed you that
we have a very new development framework
based around these cards that allows you
to build cross-platform add-ons for
Gmail not worrying about what platform
the user might be and not yeah not
worrying about what what platform the
user might be might be on and it brings
you the opportunity to bring your app or
your apps functionality to the user in
the right context what I needed most and
with that I'd like to introduce our last
partner Desna Bhargava from Intuit and
she will show you what they've built
[Applause]
can we switch to the iPhone please
all right hi everyone I'm Devin apart
GABA I'm a product manager into it
working on invoicing and to walk you
through this demo today I'm gonna give
you a perspective most small business
owner so I'm a small business owner who
owns a catering company called catering
by Deb now very original I know um
anyways as the owner
I run the day-to-day which means
anything from cooking to catering events
to managing our finances we've been
growing a lot recently which is really
exciting but at the same time that means
that we have a lot more customers and so
I need to create more invoices invoicing
is a pretty tedious but also
time-consuming job and so I usually end
up doing invoicing on my weekends when I
have a little bit more free time
invoicing right now and in the past has
for me been creating a document entering
it in with in with the items and the
services that we've provided and then
saving it as a PDF attaching it to an
email and then after that I have to
manually enter in and track who's paid
me and who hasn't paid me then I have to
send reminders so it's a pretty tedious
effort today but I recently discovered
this awesome add-on called QuickBooks
and voicing inside of Gmail it lets me
invoice my customers directly inside
inside of Gmail which is really awesome
especially because I use Gmail to run my
entire business and as my primary way to
communicate with my customers so I'm
just gonna walk you through exactly how
I create an invoice Sara Hill is a brand
new customer and we just finished a
catering event for her son's birthday
party so I need to send her an invoice
so that I can get paid and usually in
the past this would have taken me about
you know 15 to 20 minutes per customer
so now it's gotten really fast I need to
click on the QuickBooks invoicing icon
at the bottom right expand it and create
a brand new invoice Sara's information
has already been pre filled because
QuickBooks knows that I've been emailing
with her all I need to do is include the
service that we
provided for her which is a birthday
party QuickBooks also knows that in the
past we've done birthday parties and
that the we charge about six hundred
dollars per event and so it's prefilled
that for me as well
I can also see a preview of the invoice
before sending it to Sara this is
exactly what Sara will see when she gets
the invoice from cookbooks I love that I
don't have to do anything and it's
beautiful and professional so I'm just
gonna make sure that this is the right
invoice it has six hundred dollars and a
birthday party
so I'm gonna go ahead and send it to her
invoicing is so much easier and I can
even do it while I'm on the go I no
longer need to set aside time on my
weekends to invoice my customers I can
also see all the different invoices that
I've set in the past to check if
customers have paid me or not so I'm
gonna click on View invoices awesome
Devin James paid me fifteen hundred
dollars for an engagement party that we
did a couple weeks ago and in that mean
time if I scroll up Sara Hills already
viewed the invoice that I just sent her
with QuickBooks invoicing inside of
Gmail I can now have all the tools that
I need to run my business in one place
which means that I can spend more time
doing the things that I love within
running my business so thank you and if
you have any questions about how we
built it or QuickBooks and voicing
please come visit booth a16
[Applause]
thank you very much I'm super excited
how QuickBooks now makes it possible
that small business owners can quickly
send invoices right from their mailbox
it's truly nice quick please switch back
to the to the slides so now the big
question when is this all coming
available so Gmail add-ons will be
available for all consumer users and for
all enterprise users later this year but
as of today you can sign up for the
Developer Preview which means that you
will get early access to all those api's
and that you can also start building
add-ons just like our partners here
showed us if you go to G dot Co slash
Gmail add-ons you can sign up right now
and we hope to start sending invitations
very soon I'm super excited about what
we've seen today and what the
opportunities are of this of this
framework in the future and I hope you
are too
I can't wait to see what you all will be
building in the future and I want to
thank our partners very much for the
work over the past months I think their
add-ons are fantastic and I want to give
them another round of applause and thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]